[Applause]  just got fired  that ignited the crowd right there  carl anthony towns lit the match  throwing it down  on jay crowder wow and now there's some  worse going on between the two of them  they better just they're gonna back off  on all this  jay crowder  is  a tough customer let me tell you i mean  people know around the league you've  seen it wherever he's been but towns  is not backing down to anybody  i love it this is  this is like playoff basketball right  here  minnesota is  throwing some serious haymakers at the  phoenix suns here  punctuated by carl anthony towns with  the big throw down  [Music]  [Applause]  was able just to jump over the top of it  they call it double technical by the way  on crowder